Hey, everybody. Welcome to the podcast.
It's hard to believe, but it's actually been a full year
since my last rendition of coach's corner,
which kind of has been an institution here on the show.
So to atone for this grievous pandemic induced sin
today we restore balance to the universe
and we do it with not one, but two Olympians.
Longtime listeners need no introduction for Chris Hauth.
Chris is my long-time coach
and coaches corner co-host.
He's a former Olympic swimmer,
a sub nine hour Ironman Champion.
And fellow ultra endurance junkie.
Who today is one of the world's
most respected endurance coaches.
But also joining us today is Caroline Burckle.
An audience favorite
that many of you will no doubt recall
from episode 565 this past December.
Caroline is an Olympic medalist in swimming.
She's a 23 time All-American
a two time NCAA champion
and an NCAA swimmer of the year
who now runs RISE.
Which is a mentor program
that pairs Olympic athletes
with young elite athletes for guidance.
Today's episode is so good.
It's about many things, but it's mostly
about the opportunity for personal growth, for resilience
for adaptability, that athletic performance or the pursuit
of athletic performance
and this pandemic presents and demands.
But mostly above anything.
I think it's about why working out
is really about working in.
Chris and Caroline are two of my very favorite people
but the combination of the two of them together
is just completely over the top.
So without further ado, let the coaching session begin.
"Donner Party Two."
Have we all three been together
in the same place at the same time since then?
I don't think so.
No.
No
This is the first time.
I mean obviously I have seen
both of you guys separately.
We did that podcast up
in Donner when we were training for say it.
Can you say it?
Can you say the word?
Now is the time.
Is this, the test?
Otillo.
No, I don't even think that was close.
You're European descent.
I go full American for this.
I just say Otillo.
Otillo.
Don't even try.
That way you exempt yourself out of the criticism.
And I'm not in that gray zone
of somewhat insulting someone.
But as long as you preface it by saying
"I'm gonna butcher this," but let me give it a go.
Let's hear it.
Otillo.
Is that it?
I don't know.
What we really need to do is just ask
for whomever is listening right now.
I've tried it doesn't lodge
in my long-term memory though.
Send us a voice-
I have had many people say it properly.
And then for whatever reason, I can't do it.
I think when you get to a certain age
you lose that ability.
That part of your brain just gets switched off.
Even hearing it last March on Catalina enough.
From American saying it properly.
I still don't remember.
So here we are ugly Americans.
I'm having that ride for November.
You're doing November?
You're doing Catalina in November?
With my brother.
Ride on.
Are you doing the the full one?
No, we're doing the sprint.
The sprint.
It won't be the same.
The sprint is not the same experience.
I don't know.
It's an experience whiplash with...
I did the sprint.
No, I did the middle one didn't ?
I don't remember.
I think I did the middle one.
There's a short one. A middle one.
I was gonna do the long one with Mark.
But then he had a timing thing
and for whatever reason we couldn't do it.
And then I was grateful
'cause I realized that the middle one was hard enough.
That Island is no joke.
I'm just gonna pretend it's the long way.
When I told my brother
about what we actually need to be training for.
Getting like slippery rocks and whatever.
And he was like, "Oh yeah, I'll find those around here."
He lives in Louisville, Kentucky.
I was like "All right, Clark."
And I mean, he's committed.
My brother is a competitor though.
So we're gonna be-
Which is why it seems
like you should do the longer-
The long run.
That's what I think we probably should-
But there's not a lot of slippery rock in Catalina.
I was just thinking it's mainly beaches.
There's hills, but it's more traditional trail running.
It's not as technical as Sweden by a long shot.
It was completely different.
I mean, it was hard.
The terrain was tough.
But it wasn't like mountain, like orienteering
or you're not trudging through bogs-
Through the forest.
And falling down on your butt on slippery rocks.
That wasn't part of it.
It maybe part of mine.
And maybe it was just the day,
but it was super hot out.
Like I was overheated the entire-
In Catalina.
I was wishing I had either a sleeveless
or just did it without a wetsuit.
November I mean, it's hot.
What's the water temp sixties?
The water will go up.
I mean, the water will be a lot warmer than March.
68 to 70?
I will Keep that in mind.
I was so happy to get back in the water and cool down.
'Cause the running definitely overheated me.
And that was the biggest challenge.
Like being overheated, trying to run
up trails like steep hill.
The run segments were also different
than the traditional Otillo in Sweden that we did.
Are way different.
They were longer.
And you're more exposed.
There were more in a forest and shorter in and out of water.
You do these 200 liters runs and then 200 meter swim
and then 300 meter run and a hundred meter swim.
So that was definitely different in Catalina
but he also what was it?
Michael warned us.
It's a lot harder than it looks.
And Catalina was.
The long course really surprised me
as my partner is just pulling me along.
Hey, I got the reverse effect.
He was just like, "What are you doing Chris?"
I'm like, "This is way harder than I thought."
Who did you do with?
Andy Blow from Precision Hydration.
And he's quite an athlete himself
and former pro triathlete.
That's an unusual uncomfortable experience
for you and you get pulled.
The apology. He's like-
That's what I was doing to you the whole time.
So, sorry, I'm holding you back
just go ahead leave me.
That's what I'm gonna feel when I'm swimming
with my brother though.
He's gonna be charging.
Like I'm talking pace on pace, on pace for swim.
And I'm gonna be like ugh.
He's the classic top heavy swimmer.
He doesn't look like he can run up a hill.
I mean, yeah.
I think we may be even on the runs probably.
Well, I don't know. Maybe.
But you want that he'll clear the water for you
you stay on his feet and then you. Exactly.
He swims breaststroke.
I swim freestyle and will be great.
It's fine.
I mean, I think Catalina is the perfect kind of easy
first race to do.
Chris and I going to Sweden and doing this thing.
Other than that Donner trip
that we were on,
we didn't do any training together.
And it was like the teamwork aspect of it
and like maintaining proximity to your team.
Like there's a lot of,
it was amazing how many people were tethered
to each other too, which I've still never tried that.
'Cause that just I'm like I'll face plant.
I'll trip on that cord or something bad will happen.
But it helps for, if you have a super
strong swimmer that literally can pull you.
I mean, there are a few times
where Andy yes, pulled me.
Oh, you were tethered?
He was like, "Let me pull you."
Not on the run, on the swim.
He pulled me.
And it is interesting.
And I noticed this both in Sweden and in Catalina
'cause you have the European crop of athletes who come
who are doing the circuit.
And the sport has now been around long enough
that you have these specialists,
like, this is what they do.
They're not like doing this on the side
or after their triathlon career is over
like they're swim runners.
And that's a very specific skill set
that they have mastered.
And when you see them execute, you're like,
oh that's a whole other thing that they're doing.
They're so good at it.
There's no weakness.
I'm curious to see who comes for it.
The only one I've done is with Hillary.
And that was in San Diego.
In a long beach.
Which is a little different.
Oh my God.
We were like, boom.
Well, Hillary is very similar to my brother
to where strategy, strategy, strategy.
And I'm just like, "Woop let's go."
So it's like, I can I pick up well on the strategist
so I can strategize with the strategist.
So Hillary is like, "Let's do this.
This is the route, this how we're doing it."
My brother's the same way.
So it's like a good balance.
You don't have two people trying
to tell each other what to do the whole time.
And then you'll get there
and it will be a whole different thing.
Plan will go awry and you'll change it completely.
It'll be rainy, windy.
I remember watching that
and I was like broken on a couch
and just so in awe of you two doing that.
I'm so glad it was that way though.
'Cause you have next year and it was like a nice day.
It was sunny and 75 the next year.
It was a completely different experience.
So us always having that event.
It was epic.
It's an experience of a lifetime to have
that come together like that.
And for us to be in that scenario, you can't script that.
It was something else to watch.
I'll put it that way.
Seeing on my side
and watching it as it was live
and you guys were doing-
Did you watch the live stream, the whole thing?
Like I don't remember what hour
or the day it was but I was like,
I'm committed to this I can watch this.
And it was like choppy at some time,
there was points when it was just spotty
and the internet, the wifi was bad or whatever.
But you guys, I mean, I was seasick watching it
and just knowing what you all were doing
through that was inspiring enough for me.
I've told this story before,
but the most absurd moment in the whole thing
was like midway through the pig swim.
Which is like the the longest
it comes like maybe two thirds of the way in.
It's the most exposed and the longest channel crossing
in the whole thing where there's no Island protection.
So you really get the chop of the Baltic sea.
And I completely lost eye contact with Chris.
I had no idea where he was.
All the islands look the same.
So when you're spotting
on the horizon where you're supposed to go
you lose your perspective of which direction you're heading.
And the boats were pitching.
So insanely that it was like
if this was in the United States
there's no way they would let any boats out here.
And I just lied on my back-
Let alone swimmers in the water.
And started laughing.
I was like, this is the most ridiculous.
And do you remember how many
like just everywhere you looked were jellyfish
but they didn't sting.
They were a certain kind of jellyfish,
but just like thousands everywhere you at every stroke.
And I was like this-
And that was the only reason
they would have canceled the race.
It's not because of us.
The buck is a swimmer because of the boats.
They have to stay sort of in one place.
And they were getting tossed so badly as support boats
that they would have had to cancel the race.
Only because of that.
They said we don't care about the swimmers or the athletes.
And Thomas was on one of those boats.
And he had some stories about that-
Oh my gosh Thomas.
Getting sick.
Its pretty brutal.
I remember that. Those stories
The main thing I remember,
and I'll never forget is just you
and I looking at each other at the top of one
of those cliffs, I think it was right before the pig swim.
And we just started laughing,
we were like, "Are you serious?"
We had to lie down on our butts to even get
down to the place where you jump in.
It's like, we definitely didn't train for this correctly.
A and B where's the coast guard?
Like, wait, we're getting here.
Oh we did they cancel it?
And we're still just the only ones out there?
That thought process-
Did they bring you back?
Oh gosh it was quite remarkable sitting on that beach
and just looking at each other, just laughing.
'Cause that's all you could do.
You're like, all right, well, here we go.
Those are the moments that you remember the most.
Catalina won't be like that most likely.
Are you sure?
We'll see.
Well, because the hardest swim in Catalina
is the really long one on the back end
when you're already coming back
and it's just, you leave this beautiful beach.
I mean, some of these beaches and these ones are gorgeous.
And the clarity in the water is nothing like it is in LA.
Like it is very tropical.
The Marine life is bananas.
And then there's this one long swim.
You leave the beach and you swim about a mile
maybe a little bit more.
I don't remember off the top of my head
but it's these cliffs and the beautiful Island right there.
And you have to swim around a point to come back in
and onto another beautiful beach.
But you're swimming
and you're like, this is big ocean swimming.
You're just completely exposed
and the cliffs just go straight up
and it's a pretty remarkable swim the currents against you.
And you're just like, this is awesome.
It's just pretty hard-
And there's shark?
Do we need to bring Michael with us?
I don't think it's -
I don't know.
You wanna do Catalina?
I know.
How's that gonna work?
I know. No, I'm fine with them.
I just wanna know if they're sharks?
And what will that do for you?
If the answer says yes or no.
Does it change anything if you were gonna do it?
I think the general awareness.
Oh no, I'll still do it.
But the general awareness
of knowing that, okay, that's gonna maybe something-
So you gonna do the midnight start
and the whole thing you're doing the official crossing
where you start at midnight,
you swim through the night and-
I don't think ours is at midnight this time.
I don't know.
Actually, I mean, I'm almost positive.
It's not at midnight.
I remember looking at the, I think it's like
maybe 6:00 AM 5:00 AM early.
Do you know Hank Wise?
Sounds familiar
He lives down in like the Long Beach area.
Is he doing it?
Swam at Stanford with me.
Super funny goofball guy.
But he coaches kids now.
But he's done the Catalina swim a million times.
And I think like a year ago he broke the record
and he's like a couple of years younger than me.
Like maybe it must be 51 or something
like that at this point came really close to breaking it.
I think he broke.
I think he might be the record holder right now.
I don't know, but he's done it so many times.
Like I could connect you with him.
Solo?
He'll have the whole breakdown
and low down of like what to do and what not to do.
That would be great.
'Cause I like to plan, as I told you about Tahoe.
The captain is key for that too.
I mean you can shave off a ton on time.
And for Tahoe that's the main reason for me.
There's no big fish.
Let's talk about that.
Are you gonna do this too?
I have not swim at all.
I've done no swimming.
Like it sounds cool.
Like 21 miles across Tahoe, we should just preface
or contextualize this by saying
that's what Chris is getting ready for right now.
Trans Tahoe.
And so is CB.
Crossing 21 miles. You gonna do it too?
I'm also not raining though.
There's no pools.
But you have the ocean.
This morning he's like, "Oh, I swimming at Pally high."
I'm like also no one has told me that the pool is open.
40 minutes, head down.
You on Instagram, shared pictures of you on a pool deck.
I went to El Segundo Wiseburn
and they have like, I mean, I'm talking
you book it on the hour, 7:00 AM for the week out.
And if you get lucky, you get a slot.
If not, you're like one minute late.
So I got that one.
And then I got Elaine at
what's the one in Culver City of plunge.
The Plunge.
That was it.
You gotta book ahead.
Like I did that too.
And I've said this before,
but like look at the schedule.
And I'll just like book a ton for the whole week.
And then like the way my schedule kind of plays out
like I ended up making one of those swims.
You're that guy.
Where everybody's like-
Do it on the schedule.
I do it when I have an opening and I'll scoot over.
It's so that you were saying that on Bonnie
when you're talking to Bonnie, because it's so true.
It's like, you just wanna go when you feel it.
Like when you wake up in the morning
and you feel like I need to swim today, my body's sore.
I need to loosen up.
Be one with the water.
And it's hard when you just have to schedule it
in at a certain day and time.
And I don't want to go down swimming the ocean by myself.
Like just, I'm like all uptight
and like anxious the whole time.
It is scary.
You were sharing Chris
on your latest podcast episode about swimming
in the Bay and the difference
between seals and sea lions.
I'm just like oh jeez.
The seals fine, sea lions, not so fine.
And you don't it has coming up together.
They don't announce what kind
of animal they are they just ram into you.
Exactly hard.
And they're very vicious.
Super vicious.
And they're territorial.
That's the problem with seals.
Do they bite?
They'll nip you real hard.
There's definitely a bunch of South End Rowing
guys who have gotten.
Is that when they get out in the Bay though,
they don't come in a aquatic park.
That would be unusual.
Rarely, but most go out.
Most of the South End Rowing guys, go out(crosstalk).
I just saw a couple days ago,
a whale came into the Bay.
Oh wow.
There's a lot going on in the Bay right now.
There's just a lot in general.
Like there's, I mean, the weather has been
it's been the biggest surf in what? 30 years?
In LA I don't, I just made that number up.
So I think.
Is that true? I haven't heard that.
'Cause I think the don't remember when it was
but the first rain that happened all the wind that came in
I mean, it was in Redondo, in Hermosa, Redondo Manhattan
all the surfers were just like,
"This is the biggest swell we've had in so long."
And I don't surf.
So I just watch and it was intense.
I mean, pumping.
And then right after that, you see so much more wildlife.
Like when things calm down again.
It's like the changing of the tides, literally.
Like things just happen
and you go out there and there's seals everywhere
sea lions or whatever sharks and dolphins
and all these things that people are spotting and finding.
And I find it so beautiful.
I'm like, this is so cool.
That life just has this cycle of that.
And I'm just still learning so much
about all of that with the ocean in the first place
but it's very cool to learn.
Except that when there's a big storm
and all the surfers go out, they're disregarding the fact
that like that's when all the runoff in the ocean
and everybody ends up with some kind of infection.
Like I did, definitely did learn my lesson there.
Were you there?
You remember the septic knee thing?
Oh that was from that.
So now I feel like the one
that after it rains every time,
there's still some of my buddies
that will go out in the water and I feel bummed.
'Cause I'm like, "Guys, I just I've had bad experience.
That was the hospital thing.
Like I can't do that again."
And I just, I won't.
So I just, wait, I wait 72 hours.
There's plenty of days to swim.
Yeah, exactly.
And the way I see it is mother ocean has her way.
That's power.
Like we are guests in that space
and that's, I just view it as that.
I will join when it feels right for me.
And that's just been my philosophy
since I'm not a big wave surfer or anything like that.
I think you can say that with mother nature
not even mother earth.
Exactly mother of all things.
We noticed the big surf on the coast ride last week.
Did you?
Coming down, it was pretty remarkable.
How many people did you have on that ride?
15.
For us it was one for me, it was important to put
on an event and not cancel something.
And it was January.
We had to cancel 'cause everything was closed.
And so we only had about 15 that were flexible enough sort
of like calling the Eddie was like call him the coach ride.
And we had 15 people show up.
Ride down the coast and the Highway 1 is closed
because the of huge wash out.
So we had to go inland, which is not quite Big Sur.
That's a little bit different.
I mean, it's beautiful Carmel Valley and so forth.
And then next thing you know, you're in the central Valley
and there's a lot of head wind.
Flat commercial farming.
It is. But then we turned
into the old wildflower course.
And being back there again
for the first time in 15, 20 years.
That was pretty cool to see.
That's cool.
So with COVID and all the challenges
that it's thrown at us for the last year.
Here we have Chris
who's just been living his best life coaching.
He's like tanned.
Like he's super fit training for this.
Even though there's, I guess
your masters pool that's open.
Super fortunate for that.
So you've been able to get back in there.
but it's kind of been, I mean,
I don't wanna minimize,
there's obviously challenges and setbacks
but you've been basically thriving .
Self curated adventures.
And this time of non-competition.
Highlighting for a lot of people,
what's really important to them on what they're doing
on their endurance journey and what they really need.
And they realize that they don't need a finish line.
They need the experience, the journey,
the time out there the growth
and the curiosity for potential
as I like to always say.
Curious of what else I can do.
And I think this last year
because there has been no competition
in the sense of urgency, like must get ready.
They've relaxed
into becoming better overall holistic endurance athletes.
And it's been fun.
Like I've had more athletes approach me
with a new sense of purpose and better outlook
towards the future than ever before.
Because without a race, then that question
of why are you even doing this
becomes more present, you can't really run away from it.
And all the excuses around,
I don't have time to work on technique
or I don't have time to do the strength where
all the other stuff that gets packed
into kind of maximizing your potential.
That when you're busy and this is your hobby
as you always say, is easy to kind of push
across to the side like, well now is your moment like here
you can actually do all those things
and answer that question of why and get really deep
into like the purpose aspect of all of this.
But one of the things I was thinking
when I was listening to your latest podcast episode
which by the way is fantastic.
Thank you.
I didn't realize
that you have been doing this now for four and a half years.
You've become a master of this medium.
I mean, every endurance athlete should listen
to your podcasts really well done.
Thank you.
But I feel like as somebody
who's known you for a long time
you've matured so much, not just as a human being
but how you kind of communicate your mentorship.
And had COVID occurred like 10 years ago
you would have been the most intolerant petulant.
Like I don't wanna hear about your stupid excuse.
I was listening to you talk.
And I was like, this guy is like a life coach.
It really has so little to do with endurance anymore.
It's really about like life and meaning.
It is.
And so that this moment
that we're having right now
has coincided with your capacity to kind of speak to it.
It appeared as should.
If like you said, 10 years ago
I would have not been prepared for this.
But for some reason
things just all came together right here.
I was mature enough, 10 years ago.
I didn't have the wisdom 10 years ago.
I didn't have a partner who challenges me constantly
to go through this.
Like it all, culminates to this place
and now to speak more towards the purpose.
It's my enjoyment lies 100%
in helping others get that sort of deep understanding
of their why or their purpose or their path.
I mean, the biggest frustration that many athletes
that come to me have is,
that I keep telling them it will appear
for you, do not try to force it.
You can't manipulate your life path
and they don't want to hear that.
And it takes a few years
and then they'll come back and go
"You know what you were sort of right back then
I'm ready to take that journey now."
But my power meter says this Chris
and I needed to say this.
Yes. But the only way it's going to say that,
is if you let go.
It's like we know from swimming.
It's like whenever we're too tied on my today
the set is gonna be so intense.
Like you try to get yourself mentally ready for it.
And then you get there and you're three
or four repeats in and you're nervous
and you're not swimming well, and your walls are awful.
And you're just like chopping through the water.
And then it's like, well
what am I making such a big deal out of this?
And then slowly you return into what you're capable of.
And that's the hardest part that dichotomy.
Caring enough for the result and the outcome
but also letting go enough
for letting them result in outcome to happen for you.
The Eckhart Tolle.
That is literally my favorite.
Right now I'm living
in a space of possibilities on both sides of everything.
Like both things can be true.
And I don't work with older athletes like you do
but the younger generation, these teenagers
it's the same thing.
It's like this, I don't want to let go of that control
because if I let go of that control, then I'm gonna fail.
Then my confidence will go down the drain,
all of these other things
that people just hold on so tightly to.
And to let go is such a physical experience too
that you have to experience through your body
which I'm a big fan of just that whole conversation.
But I think we try to use our minds
to wrap around that to where it's like,
I'm just gonna let go with my mind.
And then yes, we can let go with our minds
but then we're just, our bodies are still tense
and our minds are trying to let go
and conceptualize this thing that we haven't actually
experienced through our whole physical being.
Which I think quarantine has allowed people to tap in
to themselves in a different way,
because they don't have
that physical outlet in the same way.
So they have to release physically through other modalities.
That's the gift of this whole experience.
When you're older and you've been ground down by life
and you've had your experiences
like you kind of slowly come
to this realization of the power of letting go.
Or like really calibrating
like what you can control versus what you can't.
When you're young, it's very difficult.
You're like, this is what I'm doing.
And this is my path.
And I've got this is my meet schedule
and this is what I'm doing.
And then COVID hits and it all gets thrown out the window.
Like how how not just disruptive,
but like completely disorienting
for a young athlete on the rise.
But they're being given this opportunity to kind of grapple
with these things that most people don't figure
out until much later.
And if they can figure that out
how much more kind of powerful can they be?
And there's nothing wrong with living
under the constructs of what you're modeled in a young age.
'Cause that's how we all grow and learn.
But like you said, as you get older
you start to unlearn the things from your past.
So it just opens up more space to create what you want.
So I think when athletes are young, they're afraid
that something that works for them is
well it's like what we talked about last time.
Well, if it works for me to do this
but everybody else is doing this
then I can't possibly do this.
Like that's wrong.
Whereas when you get older, you can kind of figure
out what works for you.
Training or off training like when you're at home.
So I am noticing a big growth in that,
where people are starting to just own
and claim their own path about what works for them
especially the athletes that I've talked to
and worked with during this time.
It's like I've had more time to actually understand
who I am as an athlete.
Not only outside,
but actually as a competitor.
Who I am as a competitor, it's given
I wanna see where these kids are gonna be
in one or two years.
Where your athletes are gonna be in one or two years.
Like after having this window of time.
I mean, that's huge.
It allowed people to work
on things they've never experienced before.
I'm excited for that personally.
What's the percentage of your athletes, Caroline
that are swimmers versus other sports?
Swimmers or water sports are the most dominant with us.
We've got water polo and swimming are the main two.
And then we've got softball, baseball
synchronized swimming, well, artistic swimming.
Really, they changed it?
Yeah, I know.
I keep saying synchronized.
Is that like a woke thing.
Like why do they change the name of it?
I guess it ain't, I don't know.
I didn't know that was artistic swimming.
I know I need to do a little more research on that
but I know that they've changed it
to artistic swimming, which is cool.
So swimming is water sports-
And is there a difference in how the athletes
that you're working with are processing this based
upon what sport they're in?
Honestly, it also depends on Olympic sports too.
So like we have a couple
of sports that aren't Olympic sports.
So it's like the seasons are different.
They have a different kind of structure and layout.
But when you have these athletes
and we have some mentors that were training for Tokyo
and it's same thing, it's like, it really threw them off.
Like it really was hard at first.
And to your point of what you're saying
they've come a long way.
But this time for those
that had that Olympic schedule
where a lot of sports follow the quad
of needs and structure.
Whether it's world championships and pan AMS and whatever
it threw a lot of people off at first.
The first initial three months were really difficult.
Really, really, really difficult.
And it just felt like what's my purpose.
Like, wow, if this isn't my path, what am I doing?
And even some of our athletes were saying things like,
"Well what am I gonna work on now?
Will, we work on mindset?
But I don't know what to work on."
Most of our mentors were saying this to us.
"So we've really gotta all come together
and shift what we're doing here."
Like how can we go through a transitional period
with unknown and uncertainty versus, okay
how can we get ready
for the ISL or the State Championships
or Sectional Championships or whatever it is.
So it was a big shift in purpose.
Like we were talking about earlier, huge.
People completely had to redo their goals.
Well you almost get kicked off the highway.
Like, let's say, you're heading on a highway
that your entire life it's pretty structured in swimming,
especially where you know where
you're gonna be in a year from now.
And two years from now, if you keep progressing
it's a pretty clear path.
And it's not like this year has just been a detour.
It's like you completely got kicked off the highway.
Too bad.
Where you're going is still out there.
But it's like, how do you make that detour side road
whatever work for you to still get back on the highway
a couple of miles down the road.
And that's the part that I find even the younger athletes
and Olympic athletes have struggled
with early of what, wait a moment.
There's no manual for this.
And we've been conditioned our entire life.
And to this day in all sports, it's like, do these things
do it like this set your mind to this and no power through
don't listen to your body, just go.
And this is how it works.
And those first few months
when you take all that structure, all that narrative
your entire identity away.
Of course you're gonna be floundering and confused.
And like you said, okay, work on mindset.
What does that even?
Because again(crosstalk).
You don't get it the pools are closed.
That was the answer.
When I was 19 if the pool was closed for like a week
I would have a panic attack.
It's so true.
You're like, well, I don't get it?
Do I just do abs?
And so there's this whole shift
where it really was interesting
to see the athletes say,
I mean, we had the artistic swimmer
that's a mentor doing her actual routines on land
over Zoom with her teammates.
And she's training for Tokyo.
She's also a mentor.
And they had the yoga things
where you put your head in
and you can do headstands,
but it's like a lifted raised.
I forget what it's called.
I mean, they're all upside down
doing their routines on Zoom
and she's sending us videos of what she's doing.
'Cause we were just like, this is phenomenal
but it was such a shift of like, but wait
the pools are closed.
How do we do this?
And in her perspective, like she was able to,
work on her own shift, but she was unique
and that she was also competing.
And the ones that the kids, she was helping,
those teen athletes got an even better perspective
based on her own growth
and what she was going through.
So she was able to grow
and also learn how to help someone else
during her own growth.
Which I think is insanely.
I can't imagine doing that when I was her age.
Like I would've been so laser focused to not
be able to like understand anything else around me.
And I think it's really allowing people
to understand their purpose outside of sport
and helping and growing
and shifting whatever they had to do
to however they had to do it.
And the athlete that can develop the stoic mindset.
I was just gonna say
when you take everything away.
Everything gone here are all these obstacles.
So we can either throw a pity party and be angry about it.
Or we go, all right here's what it is.
So I guess we're gonna do our routines on Zoom now.
Like let's do it.
Adaptation is big.(crosstalk).
I mean you would go early
in the summer, last year with the pandemic
and the pool's closed and you would go to the aquatic park.
There would be like 600 swimmers.
It was all these high school kids were swimming.
It was constant
and everybody's swimming out, along, down
to the St. Francis and back, that was their only swimming.
So you had swimmers from all
over the Bay area using aquatic park
as a launch point for swimming.
And you'd have coaches
on the rocks and on the pier.
By time and they'd whistle. It was fascinating.
I can't imagine I mean, I've thought about that a lot.
Just what it would have been like if this was
an Olympic year before Beijing.
I think about it all the time.
I mean, of course I don't know
what I would've done in that moment
but I guarantee it would have been an adaptation lesson.
Well just think three months before trials.
Oh my gosh.
The world stops.
I think that's what it was gonna be
three months or two months before March.
We're right up on the one-year mark.
So last the March, it was, I think trials.
No, you're absolutely right.
The trials are like May, June.
But I think they were gonna
be a little bit earlier this year.
I think they were gonna be late May or last year.
And so it was like two and a half months before trials.
I can't imagine.
Here you are.
I mean, and we're talking about-
Your whole life.
Little swimmer world.
But that's multiplied by a hundred sports your whole life.
I wanna see where they're gonna be in to.
I'm telling you this is so fruitful
for their minds and for their regulation
of who they are just as a human I'm so excited.
Well and it truly is
the ones who did work on the mindset piece
and really took that seriously are the ones
that are gonna emerge and have the big careers
because that's the only way that you get through this.
Well, think of the vulnerability that comes about,
when everything has been pulled out
of your identity last March.
And you've been able to work
through that and figure out a way.
And you're back in the pool of, since I think most
of them are since August or September.
They've been getting in pools.
And your gratitude, your understanding
of how special this is, how meaningful
the extra motivation, the intrinsic push you get from that.
Hopefully, many of them are kicking out stronger,
more resilient athletes than they ever
thought they could be.
They've discovered a side of themselves
that was not there before,
because we were all in the channel.
And we got knocked off that path.
And next thing you know,
it's like, wow, I'm back on the path.
This is amazing.
Now I understand what it means to dig deeper
and find a third and fourth wind.
And focus even more
and be more diligent about recovery and nutrition
and mindset and all those things.
Hopefully that all became amplified
because it was gone.
It was literally gone.
And you sat on the couch, eating a box
of Pringles going, what do I do?
I mean, it was that bad.
I mean we're not exaggerating here.
For sure.
I'm interested to see what the transition is back into.
I don't like saying the word normal,
but into it this new way of living too.
'Cause I know that a lot
of athletes are now feeling like,
I got used to this and now I'm transitioning back
and things are starting to happen
and I've got to shift again.
And that's a whole nother shift
because you regulate, you adapt, you regulate.
And then you got to adapt and shift again.
And that can be daunting to a lot
of athletes that have sort of gotten used
to the way that things were
with their training and with school.
And then all of a sudden
you're an introverted 14 year old
and you gotta go back out into the world
and there's a ton of people everywhere
and you gotta go to meets again.
And there's a ton of people everywhere.
And that is also something
that I'm curious to see
how well we can support them in that space.
Because I think that's something that's sort of forgotten.
It's still another way-
Well we all have to do that as people too.
Exactly.
I mean, I know, I feel that
even out on the highway, I'm like,
oh the 405 is lit right now.
It wasn't like this three months ago.
Where are all these people coming from?
Where are they going?
We can't be all podcasting.
Well, maybe they are, everybody has a podcast now
everybody's late into their podcast interviews.
This used to be my highway.
Now there's actually other people living in LA.
I mean, it was nice for a while.
It was open road.
It was crazy because you could go.
I was like literally driving
to the Rose Bowl pool to swim.
And it was not that, I mean, it was far
but it wasn't that big of a deal.
It's like, it's not the distances.
It's the fricking traffic.
I was the only person on line in security
yesterday at SFI, not a single person each direction.
I walked right up.
They scan my ID.
I go to the security line and the thing goes off
and they go, "You've been randomly selected."
And I look around I'm like
"What do you mean randomly selected?"
You have to change that word
'cause I'm clearly not random.
Only person in security it's pretty empty.
It's interesting because you hear like, oh
everybody's back flying,
but then, I've only flown twice this past year
but both times I was in the airport,
You just walk right in.
It is so nice though.
It is like, you get off, I got off the shuttle
and I was at this gate within like four minutes.
And you're just like,
wow this is how travel could be right.
To get on the plane.
Half the planes empty.
It was nice.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do want to snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know actually
aspire to eat better, to incorporate more whole plants
fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans
and legumes into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
And so, because adopting a plant based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everyone to experience some version
of what I've experienced
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is,
the plant power meal planner.
Our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of customizable,
super delicious easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team
of amazing nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other amazing features.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff
literally for just a dollar 70 a week,
the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com
promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off in annual membership.
All right.
Back to the pod.
I know this is a moving target,
but how is the Olympics gonna work?
Like they're not letting foreigners into Tokyo.
But there's enough people in Japan
to kind of fill the rafters in terms of attendance.
And they're being restrictive
about journalists and the like.
But what is from the athlete's perspective, working
with athletes who are getting ready to go.
What is that experience gonna look like for them?
I think they're still figuring it out.
I haven't heard anything solidified yet.
Cause when I ask them(crosstalk) it's still.
And I think that,
a lot of coaches are doing a good job
preparing them for what they need to know
but also things are gonna change again.
It's gonna be different before.
It's gonna be different again.
I think the village will be just a far more spaced out.
I'm sure with what they built
they're going to have to arrange that somehow
or build they've been building more, I would imagine.
But I haven't heard anything solidified.
So I wouldn't know definitely what that will be
like to be an athlete.
I just know that it will probably be pretty restricted.
I mean, if I was in Beijing
and we could literally only go from the village to the pool
I can't imagine what it will be like now.
That was what we could do.
And that was it.
So I'm sure
that it will be pretty tight restrictions on that end.
I mean, I think the pro sport bubbles have helped.
For sure.
Planning for that.
Kind of proving ground for how to do it.
It's going to be the bubble.
There's gonna be like a hundred fold in terms of scaling.
Exactly.
But I think they'll separate the venues more dramatically.
Like truly the swimmers and the polo players
and the divers and such, they will be in their own compound.
And like you said, one Avenue to and from
you're not interacting with other athletes.
I mean the opening ceremonies are just going to
be bizarre in general.
Like how are you putting 15,000 athletes
even mass than that proximity into a stadium?
Like how many people are going to say no to that
or even want to jeopardize their Olympic event.
So, but I also think
that those bubbles are gonna be bubbles
within bubbles and it's just gonna
be one quarantine perfect.
Biological passport, so closed off area.
I have a feeling
that it will change a bunch over and over again.
I mean, I don't know.
I think that the future will hold this though.
I don't think in four years or three years, five years
whenever the next Olympics
I don't think we're going backwards from this.
I think from the risk of virus or something
like that standpoint, I don't think it's necessarily
in the next Olympics going to go backwards
from what the restrictions are gonna be for this one.
It's just gonna be more protective
more avoiding the risk of what could be.
It was just like security
after the '96 games in Atlanta
it was for the first time everything changed to 2000.
And '92 was pretty bad compared to '88.
But '92 was Barcelona
and you're already pretty restricted and big fences
but you're still hanging out in the city with everybody.
'96 once the first bomb went off
that was it like 2000 and 2004 everything went.
So you're not going backwards from the security.
It's hard not to be depressed about that though.
It is.
Like how do you move forward with that.
And not let it rob the athlete or the attendee of the joy.
And we're not just talking about the Olympics
like this is gonna be applicable
to any large gatherings of human beings.
I mean, when I went in Beijing,
I didn't go to the opening ceremonies.
But you didn't not go
because you thought you were gonna catch a virus.
Exactly.
I went because I was worried.
Well my coaches were worried
that my legs would get too tired.
But at the same time,
I think what you're saying is true.
It's like that will be something that is taken
into consideration moving forward, especially
with the opening ceremonies and what that looks like.
But I can't imagine what that is
like for these athletes going into it.
I feel very deeply about that.
I feel it.
So it's a heavy feeling,
but it's also I have so much respect
for those that I see training
with their attitudes positive.
It's really cool to see that happen.
I don't know.
I think I would have been really tough to do.
I'm curious about the crop
of athletes sort of what you were saying
but we talked about it back
at the beginning of the pandemic
when they sort of canceled the Olympics
and made it 2021.
Who rises, who falls back,
who's on the back end of their career
and no longer wanted to put
in that extra year and put their life on hold.
Who are the younger ones kicking up?
Who would have not been quite ready yet last year-
It totally just changed the landscape.
I mean, it shifts a generation
because then they have an extra Olympics
for the next Olympics.
I mean it's this Pandora's box
that you don't know the outcome
and how, what might've changed from what didn't change.
But I'm curious to see what the storylines are there.
And across all sports,
because it just creates different rosters
and different people
and different people were like,
"No, I couldn't deal with it.
Or I didn't have access or availability."
It's going to be an interesting mix.
And all kinds of storylines and people like
you've never heard of.
Cause they're gonna emerge out of this.
The favorites are probably people
who are later in their career.
And it's like, can you hang on for another year?
Not just hanging on for another year,
but hang on in a year
where all these obstacles are getting thrown at you.
Where a lot of people are just gonna be like
"I don't need to do this.
I did my thing."(crosstalk).
Anthony Ervin would have loved this.
This is his thing.
What is he doing?
He's in Hawaii right now boxing
and he looks super fit.
Of course he is.
But that guy.
I don't count him out of anything.
He can tell you that he has no
interest in swimming and then show up
and win the gold medal.
And that's the thing, especially in this environment
he might be like, "You know what
I probably still can pop it."
Well because he's literally a master of adaptation.
Like he can adapt to anything
and I've seen it time and time again
no matter the circumstance, he's like,
"It's fine here I am.
I'm gonna kick ass.
I'm gonna do the thing."
I'm just gonna swim one length of the pool.
I might as well just show up at Charles and see.
I mean, he has no fear in that way
or he just works with it well.
But exactly like you're saying
that is a prime example of somebody
who no matter the circumstance can just
not let his mind get in the way of what his body can do.
And that's what I love about a lot
of these athletes and the ones we look
up to who just say,
"You know what, I know how to do this.
I inherently know how to do this."
It's that positive presence that they talk
of in psychology of, you've had a past narrative
of being successful in how you do it.
And you have this confidence
in the future that you can do it again.
So you can completely just focus right now
you have enough validation of the past
and you have enough excitement and curiosity
and positive thoughts about the future
so that you can put this moment together.
And he's like the perfect example of that.
He's like, "You know what
I'm not here to prove anything.
I've had the success in the past.
I know what my future holds.
And I'm just gonna do my best right here."
And it's great.
It's such a heartwarming, exciting
fun thing to watch
when you see it and play out that clean.
And that goes back also to this idea of people
that have faced obstacles in their personal life
and their life outside of the pool.
Swimming track and field like sports,
where it's all about controlling the controllables.
Where you're in this kind of perfect environment
where a lot of obstacles are stripped away
and all you have to do is execute.
My sense is that those athletes
are gonna have a harder time
with the adaptability piece.
As opposed to somebody
who's doing Otillo in Sweden.
Where it's all about obstacles
and nothing's ever the same.
You're acclimated to having to deal
with unforeseen things all the time.
Whereas in swimming it's
like every day is at the same,
and you're not used to any kind
of weird thing intervening with that.
And that demonstrates a lack
of mental and psychological adaptability
which in the construct
in which we find ourselves now is not a strength.
Like that's a huge weakness
Oh, this is a funny Florida story.
For what it's worth.
They did a great job of this at Florida.
They would toss obstacles in left and right.
Of things that could go wrong.
So we'd show up at the pool deck at 2:45
and he'd be like, "Everyone go home, come back at 1:00 AM.
We're doing a test that at 1:00 AM," or whatever it maybe.
That's smart.
Super smart.
And he used to, at one point, I think they cut.
One of the managers went in
and like cut some of our practice suits.
So we got to the pool and like, we didn't have suits.
So we had to like figure out what to do to find a suit.
And it's like literally a scavenger hunt to figure that out.
And then also be back by 3:30 or whatever.
So you're like busting home,
digging through your old crap finding a suit.
Busting back or going to the football weight room.
'Cause the managers have the boxes there of extra suits
and they're like, everyone's digging through it.
And it's stuff like that
is actually helping athletes learn how to adapt.
We didn't have a pandemic
but we all had our own individual things going on.
And I had my own individual things going on.
Everyone else had their own individual things going on
but when you're doing it collectively too
if you're a team athlete or you're on a team.
It's like you work together
and you can create that way of overcoming this obstacle.
And it worked.
I mean, 'cause what's gonna happen
when you're flying to NCAAs and your flight's canceled.
You gotta get on a flight in the morning and then-
Can you roll with it?
Exactly.
Be ready to rock at 4:00 PM for your first night relay
or whatever it was.
And that ended up happening to us.
And it happened to my brother at NCAAs their senior year.
I don't know if you remember this,
but the whole plane got norovirus.
So it's another situation like this.
So Stanford was on the plane, Texas was on the plane
and Arizona was on the plane.
And it was literally
the whole plane was the three men's teams.
And as you know, NCAA, there's like eight or nine per team.
So they're not taking up the whole plane.
Let's put it that way.
They get norovirus, all of them.
They get to the meet and it had like widespread.
Like after the first day everyone,
was spreading it, getting it.
They postpone NCAA
I don't even know. What is norovirus?
It was just another kind of virus.
That's very contagious.
It may makes you throw up like nonstop.
So they're all very sick and they postpone NCAAs.
Men's NCAAs.
My brother's senior year at Ohio State
they postponed for two days.
So all the fans were there
the crowds were there.
The people that didn't get it have two extra days.
And by the time they ended up swimming at
my brother had eaten a peanut butter sandwich in four days.
And he still wins the men's doing the breast.
But it's like to go through this process.
I remember him just being like, "I'm really grateful."
I mean, he was in Arizona for this at this time
but I'm really grateful for what we had to do
at Florida for some of this stuff.
Because it was tossed in our faces
that we had to overcome crap.
That would even the littlest of things.
So there is something to be said about
creating some sort of obstacle that's safe.
Well it's like, did you see the Tiger Woods documentary?
Yeah.
So when his dad is like making noises,
when he's a kid
like just trying to distract him
every time he would swing.
Like "Happy Gilmore".
Come on you guys know how its like. I'm serious.
We could do two hours on that documentary alone.
But that's also with the self curated
events this past year.
It's sort of a, and I was telling a lot of my athletes
like what you build yourself
and what we're executing on here.
Then when the event that's all manicured and curated for you
and you have support and aid stations and finished lines
and perfect transition areas with perfect aid stations.
Then you can apply your energy completely differently.
Because now you've done it when it's harder
and you had to figure it out on your own
and you sort of still did it.
And still did your distance
or still did the pace you wanted
or still did the event you wanted.
But now when it's nice and clean and shiny for you
now we can really put something together.
Whereas if they just sat around for a year
and did not use that opportunity once again.
I think that's an appropriate kind
of place to segue into something you were talking
about in your podcast the other day.
Which is this idea.
Well, two ideas first being to think
about not just working out, but working in.
Which is kind of what we've already been talking about
but also this idea of showing up is not enough.
Like where is the intentionality
that you're bringing to
what it is that you're doing.
And of course this is something
that's applicable to any athlete
how they're approaching their training regimen.
But in life to whatever it is that we're doing.
Particularly now where everything has been appended
and it's causing confusion and anxiety.
And we're all kind of asking ourselves questions
about like, what, why am I doing this?
Like we're all being-
It's evaluated.
We're all everybody's, re-evaluating
in their own way right now.
But that's part of what I go into there.
And that is once you have your purpose
and your clarity, you can show up with intention
because you're not questioning the goals.
You're not questioning the path.
Now you can focus all your
on to executing the next workout.
The next day at work.
This project to the best of your ability.
'Cause you're not wondering, well, why am I
you don't want to be asking, why am I doing this?
'Cause that takes everything that you have in that workout
or in that project or that vacation with your family.
You show up with intention too.
If you start wondering, why am I here?
You're not gonna have a good vacation.
You're not gonna have a good workout.
You're not gonna have a good work outcome.
And so the big thing there is
once you've have the bigger picture, the purpose.
And once you have the clarity
which is what I call the coaching, the path, the manual
the sort of map, then you can execute the workout properly.
You can execute your training without wondering
why am I doing this?
Well, how is this gonna help me?
Is this keeping me on my path towards my desired outcome?
And is this what the coach and I discussed?
It's all been laid out already.
And we know that from swimming
we're just so ingrained in this that we don't have.
Well, of course these 400 items are helping me swim.
My 400, I am better.
Of course, this set of two hundreds
with the middle hundred fly is helping me swim
my 400 I am better.
But in the endurance training world
or just in the work world,
if you don't know where you're heading
and why you're doing it,
the quality of your work is always going to be limited.
Because you're just constantly wasting cognitive energy
cognitive load, as they call it on other things
in order to make it more intentional and clear for you.
Once you have that out, you can hit flow.
You're right in the moment
because you're not worried about all the other things
'cause they've been clarified for you.
That makes me think about some questions I get asked
from athletes in general, like 13 to 18 year old age range.
Well, what does it mean to set an intention?
The concept is very new.
Most don't know.
That's not limited to 13 to 18 year olds.
Most adults that I work with don't know what that means.
And it's a very, I don't want to say nuance maybe
but to have the word intention
I think it's confusing to people.
'Cause it's like, well, I mean
I know I want to be here and it's like, well, why.
You have to kind of dig a few layers deeper.
But I get asked that question a lot
and it does make me wonder what would it be
like to have a buffer on each end of a workout.
10 minutes before and 10 minutes after.
To where you come in
and you literally lay on the floor and breathe.
And set your intention for the workout, you do the thing.
And then you get out and you lay back down on the floor
and you breathe and you set your intention moving forward.
I think about this all the time.
You do do an inventory of what just occurred.
And did you live up to the intention
that you set for that?
Exactly.
And it's intended. It's not perfect.
It's intended.
I am coming into this with an intention to do X, Y, Z
to the best of my current abilities.
It doesn't mean I have to do it perfectly.
It doesn't mean I always have to achieve it
but my focus towards that intention was clear.
And I did the best to my current abilities.
Current is very important because we judge ourselves
on our future person, not who we are in the now.
And therefore I can finish that look back
and I get a little dopamine hit.
Every time I hit an intention successfully my walls today
I swim butterfly.
Like we keep coming back to swimming
'cause it's easy for us to highlight.
But I swim my butterflies every second breath.
I didn't do every single breath .
For the whole workout an easy intention.
So that's an example of an intention for running workout.
I wanna make sure that my stride is behind me
and my heels are kicking up high, the entire workout
regardless of anything else, I wanna make sure
that I do the rest interval today properly.
I'm not gonna jog it.
I'm literally gonna sit down center myself
and prepare myself for the next best possible interval.
All those are little intentions
on how you get a workout done.
And then afterwards you go, well, it wasn't necessarily
that I feel so much different from a physical standpoint
but my sense of accomplishment
my sense of execution is so much more powerful.
And it allows me to move on from that workout.
In such a better, more positive place.
I can now focus on work.
I can now focus on family.
I can now focus on school.
Because I checked off all my intentions successfully
closed that move on.
And we carry so much with us
especially as younger athletes.
And so the next thing like, oh, I probably
could have done that better.
But that, like you said
10 minutes before, 10 minutes after is perfect.
Because then we can just put that behind us
driving from the workout back through the back home
driving from the workout or walking to school.
And creating that buffer and then going, you know what?
That was good.
That was good enough.
It was good to my expectations, my intentions, I set prior.
And now I'm gonna do it better this afternoon or tomorrow.
But for now, I'm gonna set the next intentions
for school, for work for family.
But precedent to that of course
is the clarity piece.
Like if you don't have clarity
about why you're doing what you're doing
what the broader goal is
then it becomes difficult to identify that intention piece.
And I think where some
confusion around intentionality comes in
is that it can be defined
in a macro context or in a micro.
Like, yes I'm gonna work on my walls
and my workout, like a micro intention.
But the broader intentionality
I'm gonna express my potential as an athlete.
That can be an intention, but that becomes very vague.
I think that speaks more
to the clarity piece about identity
and your values and intentionality on the day in day out.
I'm writing in my journal or I'm doing.
I'm practicing this mental habit
of being in the mindset of intention focused
I think works best
when you are specific about little things.
Absolutely.
And you nailed it, like there's micro
and macro and it can get confusing.
When it's like, well my intention.
I've had athletes-
I could just be awesome.
Or like, I wanna go to the Olympics
but then wait is not a goal.
Or like, what do you mean by intention?
And so it is something to clarify.
Those are good questions.
They're great questions.
And I honestly get humbled that they're asking.
'Cause it's like, oh wow.
Like I could even explore that a little bit more.
Maybe I need to understand the difference
between intention and goal setting
or understanding micro intentions and macro intentions.
Because it is, we attach meanings to words too.
So whatever we attached
to the word intention will be our trajectory of that.
Like you said, to someone, if intention is yoga
and saying your ohms before and after yoga.
And that's their view of what an intention is
then we have to kind of dissect what that is.
'Cause they are a swimmer
and they need to learn it maybe a different way to do that.
These are just questions I get
and things that I hear.
And I think it's very interesting
'cause it allows us to explore different avenues
of what people identify with intentionality.
And their purpose and their reason
for doing the sport that they're doing
or competing or performing in whatever they're doing.
Exactly. Spending so much time on something.
But I bring it back to a deeper purpose
and what I call the deeper why.
If you don't have your deeper, why and many
all my athletes go through this exercise every year
and it takes four, six, seven, eight tries
for them to get to their deeper why.
The cliche is I wanna be a good role model for my kids.
Well guess what?
Your kids are not up at 4:00 AM
when you need to get out of bed
and get this workout done.
So they're not seeing you.
I want to be a good role model.
I want to be visible.
Show them how hard I work
well that doesn't work.
I think that's usually disingenuous also
because it's taking so much time away from your kid.
Like it's probably harming
your kid more than inspiring them.
But to me, that's not.
And I challenge them.
That's not your deeper why.
Like when things get difficult
and when the excuses rise,
you need your deeper why
that anchor to sort of work you
through those rainy mornings when you don't wanna get up.
There's nobody watching you there.
You need to be anchored in something.
And the deeper why
if you keep asking that why enough
it goes to a pretty vulnerable place.
But if you understand that,
and that validation
that lack of attention that you got as a child that.
There's so different things in here I'd want to be visible.
I wanna be visible.
when I'm out there training people recognize me.
Well, good. Now let's start working from there.
I mean, again, you're right.
It is a lot of life coaching
but it makes them better athletes.
I mean, I would assume
that a person's an individual's ability
to answer that question well,
correlates pretty closely to how well
self integrated they are.
Like if you've done enough interior work
then you're able to feel yourself in a way
where you're gonna be able
to honestly answer that question.
But if you've never explored your interior self
then you're gonna have the flip answer.
But that's why I love endurance training.
Which is why this is life coaching.
And you would have become a life coach.
I mean, listen, Chris, if somebody had asked you
at age 19 or 20, or however old you were,
when you were getting ready to go
to the Olympics, what's your why?
You would have told them to fuck off.
I would have.
But that's the thing is I did have some work in there.
And I still ignore it.
I'm not saying that you're unique in that.
I will say most 19, 20 year old is like-
Mine was like, why
because I don't want anyone to be mad.
So it's like the why can be something totally interesting
if you get down with someones why could be-
And it's different when I'm 19.(crosstalk).
That's why your deeper, why at 18
is different than your deeper why at 28
is different than my deeper why now.
Like the tears that ran
down my face when I finally won Kona
wasn't because I finally won Kona.
It was like, oh my gosh
I just stripped back a lot of emotions
that were lurking
that I was hiding behind in this training.
And it was like, Oh my God, now that's gone.
And I'm stuck still with myself.
Oh we're going there. So real.
But that's also why I love endurance training.
Is that it forces people to spend time
with themselves and the Z two aspect.
You and I texted a little bit about this.
What I love about it too, is when you have to go that easy
you have to learn patience.
You have to forgive yourself
and you open the door to like letting go.
And then you-
You need to let go of your ego.
You have to let go of your ego.
When you let go of your ego.
All of a sudden
you're spending a lot of time in working in
instead of working out
because you don't feel, this is a workout.
It's too easy.
I'm barely breaking a sweat.
Everybody's walking past me, supposedly running.
But that vulnerability right there
that cracks the door open very gently.
You mentioned a minute ago,
like the outpouring of emotion,
when you won Kona and the realization
that you had been using your training
to kind of run away
from certain aspects of yourself.
Clearly in endurance sports,
you're gonna have person
who is in it as a buffer
to prevent having to look at them.
It can be a healthy path
towards self-actualization or it can be quite the opposite.
And as somebody who's coached a lot of people
I'm sure you've seen-
I wrote a newsletter.
Every variety of that, how do you identify?
He wrote a news letter on it.
Until today spiritual by passing.
You don't wanna go home
because you're not getting
along with your partner or whatever.
It's so real.
What are you running from?
And we get this instant validation
of doing something really hard
because it's the training.
We just ran this far.
We swam this far.
We biked this far.
We rock this far.
But it's still below the surface is still the same issues.
And eventually you can't avoid it.
Like you have to turn around and quit facing the sun
and look back at the shadow because it's there.
It's always there.
It's always sitting there bubbling below the surface.
And as I wrote today, you gotta go
through the mud in order to get there.
And unfortunately not
unfortunately I can't even use that word properly.
When I had that with Kona,
it was the validation that I could
that I was missing so much with swimming and
that I was never good enough.
And now I'm good enough, but define good enough.
And it leaves me in the same exact place.
And you're still the same guy.
Exactly.
And it's what we talk about
with goal setting in general, like, great.
You got to point B.
Now you're a point B.
So now what?
Now what's next? Point C.
There always going to be another one.
And then point D.
So that's why the deeper why
and a purpose ties into it.
And goals just become validation markers along the path
your path to where you are going as a human being.
And many of us don't really know where that path leads.
But once you start walking,
that path starts unfolding for you
and you can't manipulate how that path
where it's going to turn.
You just have to take that path and trust yourself
and believe in your past narrative
that it's worked for you so far,
keep doing the work and the path
as it was meant to unfold for you will unfold for you.
Trust in that.
It's a hard thing to think about.
I actually had this conversation with Luke Tyburski.
Who was on your podcast a while ago,
just about the whole running from the real emotions
and what's going on in your life and everything.
And I mean, I could talk about this for hours
but what you're saying is it really resonates
because I think a lot of people thin it's an either or.
Like you have to either face your demons
and quit everything you're doing,
or just keep going and ignore it until you finally break.
And I firmly believe that you can do both.
It's like, you're gonna work to understand yourself
and what it is that your, why is.
I love that
And understand it.
And again, going back to what I was saying
at the beginning is I'm in this place
where I'm really exploring
how we can make both things possible.
Because as an extremist in my mindset, my whole life
it's either or it's not end thing.
It's either or.
I either need to be doing this
or I need to be doing this.
I either need to be facing my demons and quit everything
or I need to be going here to see how hard-
Or also making harder on myself.
Exactly.
Like I wanna face my demons
and therefore work more and get.
No, that's not gonna be helpful either.
You sort of have to work with both personas within you.
Like we all have the ying and yang
the chaos and order, and the whole, it's always within us.
And the more we become vulnerable to accept that
that there are days where I'm just facing the shadow.
And there's days I'm facing the sun,
but I'm still there.
And again, our opportunity every day to work
with that a little bit is what I love about training.
Because again, working in versus working out
this isn't just for our body.
This is for our mind and our spirit every day, too.
And the more we recognize that,
the more you can click into it,
15, 20 minutes into a run.
15, 20 minutes into a swim,
or your mind starts wandering.
And the ego is suppressed and the subconscious arises
and you are having a different conversation with yourself.
And it is very powerful.
If you can click into that two, three, four
five times a week.
It's amazing.
I think intentionality can be applied
not just in the context
of what you're trying to get out of a training session
in terms of technique and fitness.
Oh, I'm gonna make sure
that I'm striking in this way
or holding my shoulders in a certain way.
But also on the working out and working in peace to say
I'm going to use this time to take control
of that conversation in my head.
And not just allow it to be sometimes it's good
for it to just to be
in that ruminative space because stuff comes up.
But other times I found like I'm gonna be more directed
about this, like, and really focus or think about
or direct my mental energy around being honest
with myself about what it is that I'm avoiding right now.
Like oh, I want to go
out and do this session because why?
Because I don't really feel
like answering all those emails.
It can be as simple as that, or it can be like
I had this thing with this person and it's been bugging me.
And that's why I didn't sleep well last night.
Like where's my part in that.
What character defect keeps recurring
that's causing this kind of issue
because this isn't the first time I've had an experience.
There's a opportunity there to explore.
And I think to the extent
that you can like leverage the working
in part of working out for self-improvement.
It's such an unbelievably
powerful template for that.
But I think it all begins with being honest
with yourself about whether your interest
in exploring whatever fitness journey you're on
is coming from a place
of avoidance or curiosity and exploration.
And I think most people don't even ask themselves
that question, if you can't be honest.
And it's okay if you're using it to run to, like, look
it's so uncomfortable over here.
I want to go over here for a while.
Like, that's fine.
There's no judgment on that.
But I think recognizing that is the first step
towards moving in the direction
of resolving, whatever, psychological, mental, emotional
spiritual conundrum that you're facing and that we all face.
Chris is gonna disagree.
I don't think it's necessarily the first step
because I think curiosity
and exploration gets you out there.
And starts setting up your future goals
and your future version of yourself
that you desire to be.
Potential comes from a sense of curiosity and exploration.
Because I'm curious about my potential of who I could be.
I have things inside of me,
signals emotions inside of me
that I still want to express
as an athlete or any in any realm.
And as you're on that journey
I think that's also a time where it bubbles up.
Where you start realizing,
huh, oh I'm sort of avoiding things.
But I think it's important to take that first step
down the path and start getting out there
whether it's in training or whether it's in mindfulness.
Whether it's in any type of other sort
of work with a therapist and so forth.
It's more about tapping into the curiosity
and following that string.
And then I think the avoidance question can start coming up.
Then the time with working in can start coming up
because again, the scaffolding is set.
What I mean by that is when we start training
especially as masters athletes, not when we were younger.
The training is a scaffolding
what happens inside that scaffolding is unique to everybody.
I might be doing a lot of mental work.
Other people might be doing physical work.
Other people are doing spiritual work.
The training is the placeholder
and what's being rebuilt in that building.
Is it a complete rebuild?
Is it some sort of remodeling?
But the training sets up the opportunity
every day to spend time with yourself.
And you might not want to go in that day.
But just sort of do a little paint job.
But other days you're like knocking down walls
and you are doing some serious work inside
and the tears come or the aha moment comes.
And you're like, wow,
I hadn't realized how badly I'm avoiding.
Or you're listening to a podcast
and something you say for example,
just trigger something, boom pause the podcast.
Keep rolling and just work with that.
Sentence or with that emotion that just came up.
But again, I think it's important
that curiosity sets up the training, the scaffolding
so that you have an opportunity every day or every few days
if you're not training every day to sort of do
that working in and working out.
I like that.
I think that's right.
For sure and I'm gonna throw another thought in here.
And this is only because I had a different way
of feeling my way through my sport.
And even after experiencing conversations
after our last conversation, Rich,
just of the power of what people experience
through their bodies
that they're not listening to.
Sure you have people
that don't feel injuries or don't hurt ever.
And I mean
I would love to know who that is.
Please tell me your secrets.
But the main thing that I notice is,
how can you really go in and tap in
and understand what it is that you're doing avoiding
or which direction I'm going
if you're actually not even present in your physical self.
And I think that can be the first sign is learning how
to connect to our actual physical beings,
to see where we feel
completely disconnected from our selves.
And that can be in training where you're literally
you feel disconnected in training.
I mean, that was my favorite term
when I felt off was I just feel disconnected.
Like my arms feel like they're doing something
completely different from my legs.
And my body is feeling exhausted, fatigued.
I'm having weird dreams at night, sweat, all these things.
And it's like, those things, tell me what I'm avoiding.
So that can be a cue into kind of what's happening.
And I think there's a lot of intellectual athletes
and then there's a lot of somatic and sensory athletes.
And I think speaking to both in this space
like if I can speak
to the sensory side where it's like,
you feel something off, don't ignore that.
Tap into that and go into that
and understand where am I sitting right now?
Am I avoiding, or am I actually doing something
because I want to, or what is my, why?
Back to that question again.
I think a lot of people use that as information
and it is a powerful tool that I think we forget.
And we quickly try to jump to the mind and like what it is
that we just know how to do and what we've heard
and what other people are doing, if that makes sense.
So really getting to know ourselves
because I'm gonna be different from you.
I'm going to be different from Rich.
Rich is different from you.
You're different from Rich.
And so it's like, however, what works
for one person may not work for the other.
But integrating the things
that you hear and the things that you learn and experience
in a way that does allow you to better yourself
and kind of figure out what path you're on.
If that makes sense.
Well, we're holding a lot too.
Of course.
And being able to recognize,
and again there's going to be many people
who are like "Not ready for that.
Don't hear anything.
Don't feel anything I've tried working in.
It's just not there."
And it's totally fine.
Again, it will happen when it's time to happen.
Exactly.
It took me a long time.
And it may not even happen in a way of awareness.
It may kind of go up in the loop and back around.
And they figure it out from a different avenue.
And it's smacked in the face
with a pandemic or some sort
of traumatic experience and boom.
Almost everybody has it.
We're all so similar in so many ways.
It's just, we're on a different journey.
But we're all going the same place.
And that is our path.
But I think one of the underappreciated aspects
of fitness and why as human beings we're drawn to it,
is that it's one of the few things.
And increasingly, so now where we can just
be completely present with ourselves.
You have to be in the now to like do the thing.
So whether you're Alex Honnold,
hanging on the side of El Cap without ropes
or you're trying to maintain a certain pace
and a set of one hundreds, it doesn't matter.
Like when you hit a certain sort
of pain threshold or exertion level
you can't be thinking about anything else
other than just executing on what you're doing.
And it forces like you to just be with yourself.
And there's something incredible about that.
Like I just got this cold plunge recently
and I've started cold plunging.
And I was realizing as I was doing it, I was like,
oh people love this
because when you're freezing fucking cold
you can't think about anything else.
You're just like, present with yourself.
Like it accelerates that you're like
immediately you drop into that.
You don't have to like meditate for 20 minutes
or go out on a three-hour run.
It allows you to drop right into that experience.
And I think that there's power in that
but I think that's the beautiful aspect of sport.
And maybe we don't even know that
that's why we're pulled towards it.
But I think the more you can kind of recognize that
that's where that little like nuclear reactor sits
in the middle for change in other aspects of your life.
And I think what we're talking around here,
is again that curiosity
to be on an edge of what you deem possible
and that challenge skill sweet spot.
Like when you're saying holding a certain set
we want to know
we're always curious about next, about potential.
We're just forward driving creatures.
I mean, that's in our DNA.
And so being in that challenge
skill sweet spot allows us to be fully present.
because if we're not challenged you'll wander.
Or if it's too challenging(crosstalk).
Then the whole thing falls apart.
Like it's that edge of a little more than before.
Exactly, that's where Alex Honnold is.
He's not bored.
Well, he's talked about that very thing many times.
It's that incremental push.
And I think there's a constant, I mean
neurochemistry just there with all the dopamine hits
and all the things that are happening
in your body and mind that when you're right
in that sweet spot, that sets up
that complete presence
because you have to.
You need all your cognitive load towards that
which brings us back to intention
which why you need the deeper, why, and have clarity.
So that you can get into that space
and you set your challenge to the skill spot.
Because via the clarity and the goal setting
you are now able to drop into intention properly.
That's why there should be buffers
on each end of practice.
I think about it so much just
about how that would have been so powerful
to have that sandwiched in there where-
Especially for us as swimmers in college
or in high school as well.
If it just became part of our routine,
we were so routine oriented.
It's like, of course I do five minutes
of setting intentions before everyone.
You don't even really understand that.
And then when you're 50
you're still doing it for every little thing.
Like how do I want my day to go?
Well, I think I could imagine
walking on the pool deck in University of Florida
and being terrified for the workout
that was about to happen.
So all the things that you're carrying into workout
and then you leave the things that you're carrying out.
It's like if that can somehow be streamlined
into maybe a way to transition better
I think we could all get into these places
of this narrow road that we wanna be on
with intentionality a little bit better.
Because it just becomes an experience
that you're used to
after a while you don't even think about
now I'm setting an intention.
Like you don't do that.
It just becomes a natural thing that you do.
How do I want this to go?
I mean, it's a constant conversation in my head.
Like, how do I want this to go?
How do I want tomorrow to go?
How do I want this next two hours to go?
And its natural it doesn't feel
like a forced pressuring situation with yourself anymore.
The conversation is just
a natural conversation with yourself.
And the beauty is there's no judgment with it.
If it's automated or if it's part of what you do anyway.
Then you don't judge yourself when it didn't go well
or you didn't achieve your intentions.
Because guess what I'm gonna set intentions
for something later on today
or for tomorrow so that
because you have the reps
you know that it's not gonna be perfect.
And so the judgment comes out of so much of this
because you're like, you know what?
I did pretty good today.
I got three of my five intentions.
And transitioning into real life after sport.
That's very helpful.
Whereas you're judging yourself nonstop
or nothing's enough and this and this and this.
Instead of being able to cultivate that
while you're an athlete.
And powering through the whole narrative we have
as kids and young adults growing up
as athletes just power through.
And back to the signals and what your body's telling you
and what your mind's telling you and all that.
That emotional intelligence that we're missing there.
Of course, there's a maturity aspect.
I get that
but it can definitely be guided a little bit better.
And one of the things I say
in my coaching is I wanna set the conditions for success.
That's the buffers.
You're setting the lane so that even
if you hit the wall on the side a little bit
you're still going back on the lane.
And setting the conditions
for our young athletes success is part of this.
Of like you know what
what is it you want to achieve today?
And look, you achieved it now let's move on to the next.
And sort of once they're done
with their athletic lives
that they can sort of say,
"Oh, well now I can still take all these skills.
And I'm actually ahead because I know how to do all this."
Setting the conditions for their future success.
I mean, it's such a brutal transition.
Oh my gosh.
That's the goal.
The idea of being
that intuition that you develop, like
we've talked about this before.
But when you're swimming all the time, it's like
if you're doing a set of hundreds,
you know when your finger hits the wall
you know exactly what your split is
and you know what your heart rate is.
Like you're so connected.
You're like that was definitely a 50-
To be fair we have nothing else to do in the pool.
It's like staring at a black line.
Like everybody else has nature.
But another thought with that,
the average person is gonna say,
"I don't know how you swim that much.
Like you're four hours a day staring at the block line.
Like it's so boring.
But when you bring intention to it,
there's nothing boring about it.
Like when you break it all out,
I'm gonna do this crazy set.
Like I'm scared, I'm nervous.
I have anticipation.
I have dread maybe all of these emotions.
But boredom isn't really part of it.
Because there's so much packed
into whatever's gonna happen in that two hours.
You're not just jumping in the pool and swimming back
and forth like aimlessly without any plan
or anything like that.
So like just disabusing people of that idea.
But then you set the intention
that creates empowerment and agency.
Because you're not just reacting
the coaches do this
and you just respond and do it.
You're trying to inject that experience
with an added veneer
of how you wanna come out of it.
Like you're taking control of it.
As opposed to reacting
and doing what somebody else tells you to do.
But on that piece of like moving into the real world.
Like if you can take that
that highly integrated,
very attuned mind, body connection
that you have when you're at the peak of sport
and apply that to the workplace.
You were talking about this somatic feeling athlete,
like if you go into your work
and you're like, I feel off
like not just saying we'll tough it out or whatever
but like, what is this telling me? What is off?
Maybe I should value that a little bit more.
It's much more of a feminine energy.
Like dudes are like, "I don't wanna hear about this."
But if you can really listen to that
and try to understand what it's telling you
in the way that you would
as an athlete at the elite level,
what would that mean?
And how would that translate
into how you're experiencing your life?
I had a really interesting
conversation about this yesterday.
Actually speaking of this with my therapist.
We were talking about transitioning
from sport and how, again-
Which is something Chris is never gonna do by the way.
He's gonna be literally-
He's like "I don't need to listen to this."
He's like, "I'm done.
What are you guys talking about?"
But we were essentially talking
about how the same things
we've been talking about
the grind, the go, go, go.
I'm gonna crush this.
And power through all of these things
that make us great athletes.
Also make us great in the workplace
because you get a lot of shit done on a great timeline.
And you get validated for it by your peers.
You get validated for it.
But then the same thing happens
and you hit the wall and you burn out
and you get tired and you don't want to look
at social media and you have nothing to say.
And there's just,
all of the same things continue to happen.
And then you go to your boss
and say, "I need a rest week."
Exactly.
And then that doesn't work.
We'll come back two hours a week.
That's a product. We should figure
out how to integrate into this normal conversation.
We need a periodize my work schedule.
But it's so real.
Again, the two things at the both end,
it's like both can be true.
You can work your ass off in the workplace
or get whatever done you want to get done
and create this business and build all these things.
But at the same time, the same rules apply.
The same things apply.
And so this middle space of that transition point
where we become disconnected
from understanding how to tap into that feeling.
I've seen it across the board with all
of my peers that have retired from professional sport.
They go ham into their life, whatever it is,
and eventually this continues to happen.
So the question is, and I still haven't figured this out.
I don't think anyone's going to figure anything out.
But what's that transition space
that you can allow people to know
that they can still be great
and power through and push it,
but also take the rest
take the time to understand yourself what your needs are
before you do end up gassed out on the side
of the road again, and the cycle continues.
And you're still running from your emotions
and you're still doing the thing.
Well I think as a coach.
You can shoulder that responsibility
and create that partnership dynamic with the athletes
that you're working with.
I would suspect that
that's gonna break down
between the people who
like that athlete who's making that transition.
If that athlete had a coach that just told them what to do
and they either did it, or they were out
that person's gonna have a harder time,
as opposed to the coach athlete partnership.
Where there's a communication and there's a back and forth
and that's a dynamic relationship.
That person is gonna be much more adaptable
to a changing environment.
Conditions again.
Conditioned responses.
I like to say how you do one thing
is how you do everything.
And so it starts with those, like you said,
with if that's how you were as an athlete
it's going to exactly carry over into the rest of your life.
But I think it's back to a control thing.
Because we want to control the outcome
in swimming, in sports and athletics.
Because we've been conditioned
and we've had past narrative
and validation of this, that you, by doing this today
you're controlling your future outcome.
The further we get into life
we realize there's no controlling the future outcome.
You can work at it.
You can help guide yourself in that direction
but there's still so much that can happen.
There is no control and doing everything
especially in the work world as,
or as adults with the outcome and success in mind.
And that's the only reason you're gonna do it
sets you up for failure.
You can't just take
on an endeavor guaranteeing success.
Oh, if I hire a coach, let's say I see it in my world.
I am hiring you to guarantee my success.
And I say to them, "No, that's not gonna work."
And first of all, you have to do the work.
And second of all, I don't want you
on this journey if you're doing it with an outcome in mind.
And so if we learn earlier on to let go of control
and be more vulnerable,
and again allow this path to sort of unfold for us.
And I know the commentary around this is always like
Chris' life doesn't work like that, where you just say
"The path will unfold for you."
Actually it does work that way.
It does work.
But it's hard to understand that.
And all I'm saying is
we can't try to manipulate the path.
We can do the best in the present moment to continue
with our best foot forward on that path.
And that's trusting ourselves.
Too often in as athletes all our life up we're 18, 19.
We didn't trust ourselves.
We trust what the coach told us or what the system told us
or that this is how you're gonna get through.
You get it from States, the national
the regional and that's how you've worked.
You don't have to trust yourself.
But in the real world, you have to trust yourself.
You have to believe in yourself and just trust
that the work that you're doing and
that the path you're taking will lead you eventually
to where you need to go.
It's a worthiness thing to do,
knowing that you don't need to be validated
from that to feel like you're worth a damn.
And that's a big thing that I hear
from a lot of retired athletes.
We do webinars.
And I don't know if webinars is the right word.
Pow wow kind of things in our space
where we have a group of retired athletes come in
and we all have a conversation
about this, just the transition.
And it's incredible to see everyone
feel very similar about their worthiness.
And if they accomplish X, Y, Z
in their career or in their projected family life
or in their we buy the house, we do this.
Or I get this raise or I make this,
or I start my own business.
It's like, it's all this feeling of,
well that's an accomplishment.
And that's what I'm used to
because that's what I was conditioned
to believe about myself.
And you were loved and a proof of that.
Exactly.
You know who Jessica Lahey is
she wrote this book called "The Gift of Failure."
She's an educator.
And she talks about this all the time.
Like she teaches young kids
and she goes, and she tour schools
and she does stuff with the kids without the parents.
And she'll be like
"Raise your hand if, everybody closed their eyes."
'Cause she doesn't want the kids influencing each other.
And like, "Raise your hand
if you think that your parents love you more
when you get better grades?"
And it's like 85% of the kids.
And so as an athlete
of course your validation is coming from performance.
When you have a coach
that's gonna give you that approval.
And even when parents are doing the best job possible
when their kid does something good
they're gonna like, be excited about it.
That all gets internalized.
So of course your whole sense
of self gets wrapped up in like how well you're doing.
And then suddenly you graduate out of sports
and you're in the real world.
A, you don't have a coach anymore.
But accountability as well.
Well maybe sometimes you do.
Rarely though.
In fact, that's something I think should change.
It's like why shouldn't we continue
to have coaches our whole life
for the things that we're trying to do better at.
But it's unbelievably disorienting.
Yeah, it is.
And I am a firm believer
in coaching your whole life.
Somehow some way whatever realm it is.
'Cause you need that accountability
especially if you've been raised that way
to be seen for your accomplishments
somebody that can also not just see you
for your accomplishments, but help grow out of that space
of needing that validation for what it is that you've done.
And it's very difficult.
I mean, you were talking about the transition.
Well, we don't know you may never transition.
We were talking about the transition to it's.
It's not just sports.
This is across the board
with any major life event that happens.
These transitions are inevitable.
And so I have friends that have had babies
and it's like the postpartum transition.
And things like that are just so intense
and so difficult to work through
for some people, not everyone.
Because it is this Mecca
of what you set out to think that you should feel.
And then if something ends
up different than what you should feel too
then that causes some sort of depression.
Which a lot of athletes go
through when they're transitioning.
Well, I thought it was gonna be easy.
I thought it was gonna be success again.
I thought I was going to be
at the top of my field right away again.
Or I thought, I thought this again.
And it's like, oh damn I'm not.
Now I got to start over.
I got to sweep floors at Lulu lemon,
on Saturday and Sunday, like shit.
That isn't what I signed up for.
Or like Lolo Jones working at the juice bar.
Exactly right.
Oh, that documentary hit me hard with that
because I could just feel her in that experience.
Because there is this expectation conundrum
in your head of what things will look like
because of this amazing thing that you've just achieved.
And so again, across the board
I think we set ourselves up
in that way and rightfully so.
Dream big, want great things.
Well, it's in our DNA, it's in our evolution.
That you get validated for standing out in the tribe
and that those behaviors and characteristics
and values allowed you to be a better member.
And so it's very deep in us.
But again, like you're saying
it's when you get the rug pulled out from under you, like
let's say that Lolo Jones example
that's a little bit different
than a transition of, don't get me wrong.
I have plenty of athletes who come to me.
I'm having a baby in six months, but after six months
it'll take me about three months to get back.
And then I wanna qualify for Boston.
It's like, Whoa, all right
we've got to work through this a little bit differently.
And I'd like you to know that, that transition
like you just described, there's going to be a lot more.
You are not going to be the same person
on the other side of having that child than you are now.
And despite what you think, you won't
you just a different person.
And the transitions in that space become the part
that you are connected deepest to yourself.
That's the vulnerability and a space
where if you took the time to look into that
that there's the growth in that mud is the growth.
But I just wanna go to Boston Chris.
And then you can't
there's no way you could ever shoot something
like that down either.
Like, I'm not gonna say, "Well, no, that's, well
let me break it to you
that's gonna be pretty tough."
I don't shoot it down.
But I say, "We'll cross that bridge."
Of course.
Like you have to hold space
for the other version of themselves.
That's gonna come out on the other end of that.
Because it's gonna be somebody that could even
achieve more than what they've just set out to give you.
And be the growth that is possible
that I get actually excited
because I'm like, you know what?
You don't get it yet.
But if you kick out on the other side of this
and you can grow from this, that I have my mitts on you
for the next nine months.
Hopefully you'll kick out going
"Oh my gosh, I had no idea,
but now I'm armed so much better for my future."
As a mother, as a athlete, postpartum, as I can avoid a lot
of physical and mental difficulties.
Because I've been told
the big secret post children, like it is hard.
It is lonely.
I'm disconnected from my body.
I have no clue what's going on in my life.
I mean, there's so much going on there.
But if you have somebody that maybe not a guy like me
but there's plenty of professionals out there to say
"You know what this is all part of it.
This is what to expect."
But at least educating them on that.
Like this is out there, be ready for it.
And you think you might be prepared.
But when your mother
and mother-in-law finally leave
and you're alone in the house
and you can't sleep and you've totally look
at your body and you're not getting any training done
and you're like pooh
that's when things start going south.
And it's hard to prepare.
I mean, you can prepare people for these things
but everyone's experience is going to be different
through that transition, no matter what.
You just said with experience
and her going into those classrooms
I think the important thing there is too,
like you said, allowing ourselves to fail.
And a lot of good coaching
in my opinion is exactly that.
Allow setting the conditions
and environment for you to fail.
And having a guide, mentor, coach to say,
"You know what?
That was expected.
You should be here.
And that is awesome.
Now, what are we gonna do with it?"
How are you as an athlete learning to go forward from this
using what you just experienced with me, helping you
along the way, guiding you forward, failing forward.
So that then you're going to be a better, smarter, stronger
better athlete post this.
But you have to go through those failures.
It has to be a tactile experience for that individual.
You're performing as a coach, some form of inception
because you could just say, "Here's what you need to do.
Why aren't you doing this?"
But the letting go and the allowing allows that person
to then see where those edges are, whatever fail.
And then they can like take ownership
of it in a different way.
Like they get it in a way they wouldn't
if they were just trying to follow your lead all the time.
There's a theory out there that, you know
I think it was a quote by Bismarck who said,
"I don't wanna learn through experience.
I wanna learn through other people's experience
so I can avoid those mistakes."
No, in my opinion, no
because I am incorporating, I'm learning, I'm working in
and working out when I'm going through those failures
I'm able to analyze it, feel it mentally
physically, spiritually, completely different.
Going through that.
Because was Mark didn't have teenage daughters.
That's a good one.
Very true three of them.
I mean look, I'm a woman.
I can speak for that side of it 'cause it is very true.
I think there's like when you're saying,
he wants people to avoid these mistakes
before they go into it.
I get so frustrated when I hear people wanting advice
or telling me how to do this
or please tell me how to do this right now.
And it's something I'm working on
not getting frustrated with
but it is something that is difficult
because I just so badly want to just say
you have to learn this through your own experience
and take an integrate things that other people have said.
And showed you so that you can then integrate it
into your own body and your own experience.
It's like, you don't want to be the next Serena Williams.
You wanna be Coco like you wanna be your own athlete.
And I think that that is something I'm so passionate about.
And I get all the fields about that
because it's a powerful thing as we evolve in society.
And there's a lot of information out there.
And there's a lot of people telling you
how to do different things
and coaches telling you,
"Well this is the way to do it."
And it's like the ones that can walk
alongside you and allow you to fail forward
and allow you to make your own mistakes.
It frustrates people.
It's very frustrating for sure.
It's hard to be in that position.
Well, but it's also frustrating for the athlete.
I'm used to watching it now
because it's very predictable.
But A there's an industry out there
of coaches who will shortcut it with you.
That's my job.
You, hack the system by working with me.
I'll get you around those shortcuts.
Well A in the endurance world, we know
that especially doesn't work.
But B it's also the athlete
the person, the coachee thinks that
because they hired you.
They get to jump ahead in the line,
ahead in the path of life.
And it's like, no good coaching is mentorship.
Being a few steps ahead, maybe, and saying
"You know what, when you grab that branch, be careful."
You're still gonna grab the branch
as you're climbing the tree, but just heads up right now.
Or what I like to always do is imagine a good coach
is the guy who stands by or the girl who stands behind you
and just takes your shoulders and goes just this way.
Just a little bit.
You're still going your path, but just a little nudge here
and there so that you again are heading
with those buffers bumpers.
Setting the conditions to get to where you wanna go.
What kind of athlete were you?
Did you want the answers?
What did you like?
No, I was such a scared little kid.
And that's the funny thing is I had
I just talked about this, I think
on my podcast about how I never won anything.
I always had bigger, stronger athletes
around me that were just awesome.
They were just, six foot, two.
Big, I mean, in like middle school, like these icons
and I was always just the little kid.
I always felt never good enough
part of the tears back then too.
Like, it just was never good enough.
I was just always below the surface of feeling good enough.
And so I stood there with the puppy.
I did everything and oh, you want me to sleep more?
And then I tried everything.
So I was very compliant
but I also loved the structure and the discipline.
So I think I was coachable
but I think that the coaches were bored with me.
Cause they're like,
"He's just too like, oh my gosh, go away."
Compliance will take you pretty far.
Like there's the person who can read all the books
and they get it and they actually apply it in their life.
And they can become amazing
in all different kinds of things.
And it's the person who is the creative thinker.
Who's pushing the boundaries and like refuses to comply.
That's the problem athlete or the problem student.
And when you're a kid and you see that guy
you're like, don't be like that person right.
In my experience, quite often
those become the most amazing people
because they're trying new things
and they're refusing to just take things at face value.
And that can go off the rails, of course.
But in the right circumstances
they become the most interesting people
the most successful people
the most creative people in so many ways.
So a lot of it is disposition.
Some people are just wired in different ways.
But I think about that a lot.
Like I've talked about that with John Moffitt.
Like he was like that as a swimmer.
I was the same as John.
And I was like,
how come he's not doing what the coach said?
Or the kid in middle school who was cracking jokes
and then becomes like,
Jonah Hill and gets Academy Award nominations.
It's like he got thrown out tossed out of Boulder,
like his first year of college.
But when those people
find their right lane they become amazing.
Or as I like to say it, the lane
that they were destined to be at anyway
and there's children that comes out anyway.
There's not enough narrative.
Dirt in the way for their more natural self to come out.
And that's what the kids we remember.
They're like, "Wow, that kid was different
or creative or always loud
or always rambunctious or couldn't sit still.
But that was the true them
before society sort of-
Squeezed it out of them.
You must be like this.
Which is why it's like,
if you're gonna grab that branch
you might want to think about that.
When you were telling that story,
it reminds me of like sponsorship in AA.
Doing this for many years.
And it's like, you get crazy calls.
And people are like, "Well
maybe you need to go out and drink some more."
And they're like "Let me know how that goes.
Call me next week."
It's like I'm not telling you not to do,
well it sounds like you really want to drink.
So maybe you should.
Allowing them-
They have to like make that decision for themselves.
For sure.
I appreciate coaches like that though.
I really do.
That allow you to, like you were saying, fail forward
make the decisions for yourself.
And I think I was more of the John Moffitt type myself.
So I can only speak to that.
But my brother's the exact opposite.
He's very much play by the rules.
So I grew up very close in age to somebody
that was exact opposite of me.
And so it is interesting to have that experience
as I reflect back now on coaching and what that looks
like growing up and how that can evolve and change.
And how the athlete can also evolve and change.
If they are someone that is a rule follower and this
and this, they can use that to their advantage
if they choose to, to become great.
That can actually play into their advantage
in a way that I wouldn't understand.
I wouldn't be able to begin to understand.
But there's a lot of that going on.
You have the athletes like John, where it's like-
When that comes out in you though,
like what you're talking about
like either end of the spectrum, the rule follower
or the more creative again, once you're connected
to what is your source and what is your path?
You can just blossom.
But if you just continue to ignore that,
you're never going to find out.
You're just going to be bouncing from spot to spot.
And that's the classic like, well,
what am I destined to do?
Or what is my path?
Even in that question.
Well you got to sort of get dirty
and keep doing a variety
of things to find that where that sweet spot is.
And that's those first years from college
until like your mid thirties.
Well you just got to sort of, it's messy.
It's meant to be messy.
And I think we should disabuse people of this idea
that you're supposed to just have it figured out.
No.
You're never going to.
And you're allowed to change
as many times as you want.
And I hope you don't.
We hope that don't always
have it figured out then there's no passion
and purpose and failing forward and curiosity
and excitement and what potential says.
I don't have it figured out.
I wanna keep going along that path.
That's like David Epstein's book "Range,"
he has all these case studies of all these amazing people.
And have you read that book?
No.
So it kind of upends the 10,000 hour role idea
and looks at all these people who have excelled
in a variety of walks of life
from math and science to academics
and sports and art and creativity.
And the overwhelming majority
of people were people who were dabblers
for a very long period of time.
Like the Tiger Woods are few and far between
but I can't remember, is it Federer?
Like one of the great tennis players
was like a soccer player.
Federer.
He did all these other things
before he ended up specializing in like-
As Rafael
Van Gogh.
All these people have like a million different jobs
before they finally figured their thing out.
And then all of those experiences,
in retrospect all line up
to inform the greatness that later blossoms.
All paths usually lead to one eventually.
Exactly.
There's that as well as the first part
of your life and the second part of your life
and you can be a phenomenal exceptional mastery type
of athlete or creative or musician
or artist in the first part of your life.
And you might then most cases
I'm not saying a hundred percent
you hit a wall and then who are you going to
be the second half of your life?
And that is the biggest challenge then.
Because then I know Tiger's an easy example.
The dominance, the athletic ability,
the skill, the intelligence around it
but now still just golf.
And of course, family and so forth.
I don't know him and I don't wanna judge that.
I'm just saying the, the path runs out.
And at some point you hit, what's called
that second mountain where you have to be the author
of your own life.
And where you tap into the things you've learned
in order to then express your path.
Express the truth of who you are.
And that's what to me is most fascinating as we get older.
And those first few years out of college and stuff,
where you're doing all those things.
It's all tools for that second mountain.
When you want to be the author of your own.
We all have to follow some sort of rules
if we want to make some money
a career path and so forth.
But then once we kick out of that,
it's not just another car
it's now, what can I do with this one great life?
Mary Oliver's quote.
I mean it gives you so much freedom.
The fact that you dabbled as well
as that you were open to finding yourself and your path.
And on this road
everyone just wants to be seen for whatever they're doing
in whatever timeline they're doing it on.
And that's something across the board is sort
of the underlying theme with all pursuits
at any point in life.
I suppose it it feels terrifying to want to be seen
for things in your life.
When you transition from sport
or when you're in sport
or when you're an athlete to a coach.
It's like we all just want to feel seen
for whatever it is that we're going through in that moment
regardless of if it's succeeding or failing.
And I mean, I know I'm going off on a little tangent here
but that to me, allows us to feel safe enough
to continue doing 10 different things
like Van Gogh and trying to figure out your way.
Otherwise you're just trying to nail something
down in order, again
to be validated so that people think you're great.
Or I got to go get this big job
and everyone loves what I'm doing.
But if somebody can see you
for your paths and what you're doing
it's such a different experience
to feel accepted instead of validated.
If you follow my-
But you have to do that for yourself first.
Totally and it's hard to see yourself.
It's hard for people to look at themselves going in concept.
It's hard to feel like you want to be seen for something.
Even the people in our lives
that we would never think that about
that they have no problem being seen here I am.
There still something in there
to where they want to feel understood, seen, accepted
loved all of these themes throughout the process.
And again it's the underlying thing,
the worthiness, the feeling seen
so that you can feel like you can conquer
and go through any stage or any version
of yourself in your life that you're going to take on.
Back to that positive present
that their past narrative has shown
that it works validation.
I feel accepted at that.
I've done it before.
I can therefore immerse myself in the now
'cause I'm confident you're past validation
and narrative that it will work out in the future.
So I can be creative.
I can be in the moment I could be on that challenge, skill
sweet spot and not worry.
Because I have been accepted.
But that's also brings us back to the pandemic.
With this whole year with a lot of people
not being comfortable with being by themselves.
Because you're back to, oh shit.
Now I have to see myself and accept myself.
So there's the flip side
of being seen too just being seen by yourself.
This past year, there are countless people
in my direct world and extended world
where I would I just sit there and I'm like, gosh
you should just spend some time with yourself.
It's okay.
But despite that the pandemic
could have provided an amazing opportunity
for some of those people.
And that's something I feel is often overlooked
spending time with yourself and your thoughts
and looking at yourself in the mirror
and being comfortable with that.
It being comfortable.
It's uncomfortable.
It's terrifying for a lot of people.
It's like the worst nightmare for many.
It's very terrifying because it means-
You set up your whole life to avoid having to do that.
And then pandemic.
There so many ways to hide behind it too,
again going back to the sports or just hiding
behind anything that you possibly can
so that people don't really have
to see you and your struggles and your vulnerabilities.
And you don't have to confront that.
You don't have to confront that.
You don't have to see it
because if you see it, then, well
there goes the spiral of I'm a failure.
I'm not enough. I'm a mess.
You see it, then that fear that's you're repressing
might actually be real.
As well as if I see it, others must be seeing it.
So then you get that sensation in there too.
Like, oh I know it's but again
it's every now and then stopping, turning around
and facing the shadow versus just constantly looking
at the sun and striving for that.
And like you said earlier, pausing and taking some time
and checking in like, is everything okay?
The power of the pause.
I think that that this is a good
as time as any to hit pause on this then
been going on for a couple hours.
We can do that.
We have to talk for five more hours.
To be continued.
Chris I think coach's corner
has just been extended to Caroline.
Did I make it? I did it?
It's been nice.
I'm joining the team.
It's been great.
Great I feel very fortunate to be here with you.
Quite honestly, we needed a female.
We did. We definitely did.
I provide the yang to the-
It's awesome. This was great.
This is great.
So Chris, you are planning
on swimming across Lake Tahoe in August 21 miles.
First two weeks in August is the window
because the water is the warmest then.
Still 65?
66, something like that.
Historically it could get up to 68.
If I pray.
No wetsuit so you should put on a little bit of weight.
I'm thinking about 12 to 15 pounds.
There's no indication that you've done that so far.
This is me and my swimming years.
It always like, "What's the little kid don't here?
Wait. So are you gonna coerce myself to come up there?
I'm definitely coercing you
because you need it to get ready for Catalina.
I've done less swimming this year
than I have in my whole life.
I mean, look, we could give it a go.
You don't have to swim many times.
You can just jump in once.
What do you mean?
Like what?
We still need to talk
about the structure of this race.
So it's, I'm not looking, it as a race.
Its not a race.
I'm not looking for the record
which is 8:45 or something like that.
Who has the record?
It's a woman, which is awesome.
Lets go.
And a pretty fast guy tried it last year.
And he only went only 9:30.
So that's a significant difference of,
what she said, her name escapes me right now
but not looking to set the record.
So those who look to set the records, start at midnight
and swim through the night
because of the winds on the Lake.
But I have no interest in swimming through the night.
I like daylight and sunshine and getting warmer.
So I was thinking of starting around 4:00 AM
and swimming in the sunrise.
And then when the is truly miserable
like six, seven hours in that the sun is
at its highest point.
And then you're done.
And then eventually I'm done.
I can still have dinner
a normal meal that night go to bed.
Versus being shelled for two days
for a lack of sleep at night.
So it'd be middle of the week on a Wednesday
because the Lake's emptiest.
We have kayakers, we have boats
and a bunch of swimmers, people jumping in for certain legs.
So your brother should jump in and all that.
Well, he can't come.
No that's right. There's a wedding.
There's a wedding or something like that.
But I mean, he'll be there for Catalina after.
I'm down. I just need spell out the deeds.
Tell me how much I'm doing here.
It's 21 miles.
I'm gonna pop in.
You should come up and pop in.
And its so epic to swim in the middle of that Lake.
And it's beautiful.
I have done that relay.
the transplant or relay thing
that goes across the short end.
They don't go end to end.
And we start South at camp Richardson
and head North to incline.
So it's sort of a diagonal length of the Lake.
There's not really that much about it.
We got to stick to open water swimming rules.
So no wetsuit, no touching the boat and being fed.
No being fed.
Being fed versus touch the boat and grab.
You can't hang on the boat.
So it's a question of water polo,
but there's sort of like lacrosse stick type of -
I'm over here like "Pass me the goo."
You'll find depending on your crew
how well they throw it out.
I'm like, it's just swimming to get it.
It's like a bobbing Apple.
You actually swam 23 miles.
'Cause you kept having to get the trash
that people were throwing at you.
And it's 37,500 yards about that gives you an idea.
Look I'm down.
It just, I need some prep.
And so in the prep
it's going to be a fair amount of Lake swimming
starting in June late May wetsuit
just to get used to long Lake swim.
So I spent my time at Donner three miles length
so I'll do back and forth.
So I'll build from six to probably all the way to
I won't go more than 16 in training.
So it looks like we need a Donner repeat.
But we'll choose Tahoe.
Go longer there.
That could be fun.
I feel like it would be nice to have something
to look forward to other than Catalina.
It's always annoying in the moment
when you're like, oh, I don't know.
I can do it.
And then you put it on there
and you go and you're like "That was epic."
I know.
In swimming I've never done anything that long.
You've done 10 K's though.
I've done 10 Ks,
but I mean this is a lot longer than six miles.
So four times as long.
I know.
And Caroline, you've got Otillo.
Otillo in November.
I'll probably do this.
I think we'll be like three
or four swimmers all doing the full length.
I think it would be really cool.
I mean, we could get another boat too.
You can just do two team too.
For, four swimmers,
we'll want a second motorboat just to supplies
and people back and forth and then a kayaker.
And you've got Jamie Patrick involved?
Didn't he try to go the outline of the lake Rainier?
He runs the Lake Tahoe Swim Association
and he was the first person to do the double.
So I crewed for him.
He swam down and back.
And then he tried the outline
and he's done single crossings like four or five times.
How many miles is the perimeter? It's got be-
Well on the bike it's 73 miles.
So if you figure a little bit smaller.
So probably 68.
That's a whole different endeavor.
And there's things that go through your head
obviously when you're training this stuff.
But then I always keep saying,
"Whoa whoa, whoa, whoa
we'll let's first do 21 Chris."
I think we should do the backbone trail maybe next year.
You're about to do tomorrow with Billy Yang's.
But I'm not doing the whole thing I had a hamstring pull.
Who's joining Billy for that?
He has about 10 of his Patreon podcast listeners.
Who are good ultra runners.
I knew that there was right
at the beginning of the pandemic.
I think Courtney Dauwalter
was gonna go for like a record or something like that.
And that didn't happen-
Well 'cause she did the...
No, it's just, just basically listeners
of his podcast and a couple of friends of his.
But she then went on to run the whole length of Colorado
or something like that, that full hundred mile run.
She was forget that backbone stuff.
And then I have about nine athletes doing it too.
This came up in December where we're like,
this is when the California shut down.
The second, the strict one happened.
I was like, we need something
through the winter to train for
and to look forward to
and that coincides with the rest of people's seasons.
And so in a major hub, like LA having the backbone trail
which is beautiful and epic 67 miles
with 13,000 feet of elevation gain, people can fly in.
It's easy and they're off tomorrow morning at 5:00 AM.
All right. I'll have to figure out
what time it's gonna be passing through.
The backbone literally runs through my backyard.
There you go out there with a sign.
But that's like around the 30 mile run.(crosstalk)
And just going its crazy.
"You looking good."
You want some water?
Throwing goos at them.
The hose is over there.
I mean, I'm all about also creating our own adventures.
So I think we could muster something up next year or so.
All right.
How's your running though? Are you able to run?
I run a little. I don't run a lot.
Honestly. I don't run like you.
I'll go out and I'll run like three four mile.
Nobody runs like him.
Like I don't care.
I think I'm also in a space where I don't need to run
to feel like validated with myself
which took me a really long time.
That's good.
But now I just, I love like just going out
and running for like two miles jogging, walk, run
and I'll do like five to six miles.
Just walk, run, kind of jog, run thing
where I have the intervals and the different things.
I like that way better than straight running.
I can't do the concrete pound in the concrete for 10 miles.
Forget that.
I don't do that either.
All right.
Well let's do this again.
Maybe in Donner.
Since that's where it started we'll see.
Full circle.
In the meantime where should I direct people to go?
AmpCoaching.com for Chris
And then a weekly word podcast.
That's right. Caroline?
I have website Carolineburckle.com.
And Instagram @caroburckle.
I don't tweet.
I don't do Facebook.
You're a beast on Instagram though.
I'm trying.
I'm a little dull at the moment.
It feels like the same thing every day kind of thing.
I like your artwork .
I think your artwork is quite great
how is that going?
Its great.
You have like a clothing line at all.
I'm really loving it.
I actually started a swimwear line before COVID
and then I had to stop cause I was manufacturing in LA
and they were only taking current customers instead of new.
But I could start again now and they're open.
That's awesome.
I mean the artwork has been pretty remarkable.
Thanks. It's a good balance to rise.
It's like thing into it all its really nice.
That I can imagine.
We'll talk more that next time.
Cool we have our new conversation.
To be continued. Good to see you guys love you both.
Thank you.
Peace.